what can make you angry
a lot of things first thing that comes
to mind is losing anything
uh have you ever cried after a game
when I was young I cried many many times
here after that you made many well-known
and famous people what was the most
memorable acquaintance the most
memorable I think was Crown Prince of
Saudi Arabia he was a very imposing
figure
I would say I don't aspire to being
famous but overall it's more positive
than anything
who would you like to be if you if you
hadn't been Magnus Carlos
I don't know Messi Maybe
we learn by the way
and what is your greatest fear very
superficially I've always had good
health so if I were to lose that
would not be good last question what
makes you happy Harmony